I've been struggling with an idea
recently that I was thinking maybe you'd
be able to help me out with.
Basically in a recent interview you
talked about how myth is meant to
reconcile inherent contradictions in
reality.
Right?
But I'm sort of stuck between two
mythological or,
um,
psychoanalytic ideas that I think are
both really important,
but they seem to have a inherent
contradiction within them that I've been
trying to figure out.
So on one hand you have this idea that
there's times in your life where you
have to identify things in yourself that
are insufficient or there's a problem
somehow that you have to kind of have a
controlled burn or like a phoenix like
transformation where you discard part of
yourself that doesn't fit or it's not
working.
But then on the other hand,
you have talked about this,
this union idea where as you become
really,
when you get older,
you mature by reincorporating.
Things about yourself that you lost when
you were younger or that you know you're
trying to integrate your shadow or
you're trying to find parts of your
personality that,
that maybe you've been rejecting and try
and figure out how to bring them into,
into the folder and the whole.
So he's got this quote that I really
like,
which is I'd rather be holding good.
Right,
right.
So,
so on one hand you may identify
something as a problem and you want to
get rid of it or burn it off.
But then on the other hand it seems like
the,
the path to being stronger is to figure
out how to put everything together.
So there's the,
there's the,
one of the things you wrote about in his
works on Alchemy was an explanation of
the prime l chemical dictum,
which was solvay Coagula,
which meant dissolve and integrate.
Right?
So,
so imagine this,
imagine that.
Imagine you had a fairly hostile father
who was not very well controlled and his
aggression,
decent person.
Other than that.
But let's say that.
And so your reaction is,
I'm never going to be aggressive.
And so you've built a like a moral
structure that's part of your
personality and there's possibility
floating around.
Outside of that,
did you.
You've denied an ethical,
you've denied any ethical.
What would you say?
You've stripped the idea of aggression
of any ethical utility whatsoever.
Okay,
so what happens?
This burns off and then that comes back
up.
Now you still have to integrate it.
So it's associated in some sense with
niches,
ideas,
morality as cowardice.
Because one of the niches,
most trenchant critiques of traditional
morality,
let's say,
is that most of what passes for morality
isn't reality.
It's just cowardice.
It's not that I'm a good person and I
don't hurt you.
It's that I'm afraid to hurt you and
because I don't want to admit that I'm
afraid to hurt you.
Then I say I'm moral because then I can
mask my essential fear and cowardice in
a guise of morality.
And that happens far more often than you
would think because harmless and moral
are by no means the same thing.
So some of what you're burning off you
can sit,
and this is where freud was such a
genius,
I think is because he concentrated on
aggression and sexuality,
which are perhaps the two most difficult
parts of a personality to integrate so
that,
um,
the,
the hyper simplified morality stops you
from tapping into deeper recesses of
your psyche.
And it's partly because they are primal
forces.
It's not surprising that you don't want
to have anything to do with them,
that you stay away from situations where
they might make themselves manifest.
But the problem is by denying the worst
in yourself in that manner of
suppressing it,
you preclude the possibility of the best
because no one can be a good person
without integrating their capacity for
aggression.
Because without that capacity for
aggression,
you cannot say no because no means if
you really say it,
no means there isn't anything that you
can do to me that will make me change my
mind or,
or conversely,
it means I will play for higher stakes
than you will.
And unless you've got your aggression
integrated,
there isn't a chance you can say that.
And if you did,
no one would take you seriously because
they'd know it was just a show.
So one of the most useful things that
you did,
I think was to work on this idea of the
integration of the shadow because he was
really interested in the idea of evil,
right?
Especially working with trying to parcel
out what happened in Nazi Germany during
the Second World War.
What do you do with the part of you
that's aggressive and potentially
malevolent?
He just crush it.
That's the super ego response in some
sense.
Do you just put it behind you,
so to speak?
Is that a possibility or do you admit to
its existence and bring it into the
game?
And that's C for.
For Freud,
in some sense,
morality was super ego clamping down on
the bed and there were fundamentally
opposed.
Both human piaget had a different idea
and I think they were right.
It's like,
no,
you invite the bad guys out to play,
and so you're an aggressive hockey
player,
but it's disciplined aggression that
makes you,
gives you access to the whole sorts of
energy you wouldn't otherwise have.
And then with regards to sexuality,
it's like,
well untrammeled promiscuity doesn't
constitute a virtue,
but neither does unavoidable virginity.
Right.
In fact,
I think that's worse because it also
masks itself with virtue.
It's like,
well you should be able to.
You should be able to do things that you
wouldn't do.
That's a,
that's like the definition of a
genuinely moral person.
They could do it,
but they don't.
That's not cowardice.
And so that's,
you burn off the things that get in the
way of that integration.
So
when you say dissolve and integrating,
yeah,
it'd be a good way to sort of bring the
two ideas together that the burning off
and the difficult processes necessary
because the elements of yourself are
structured together in a rigid way that
is not working properly.
Yeah.
That's what happens to Japan in the
belly of the whale.
He's so caught in his presuppositions
that he can't escape.
Right.
And so Pinocchio represents the new
forest.
So it's very interesting.
So when You Watch Pinocchio,
tried to rescue him.
The first thing Joe Petta does is
Confuse Pinocchio with a fish because he
wants something to eat.
But Pinocchio is better than something
to eat because he could rescue him so he
doesn't need to eat.
And then Pinocchio wants to make a fire
engine pedo objects because he's going
to burn up all the furniture.
So like we don't need the damn furniture
if we're getting out of the whale,
you know,
and so,
so Japan and he's old.
So that,
that's,
that's the,
that's the rigid structure.
That's the old gear that has to die off
before the new year can be born.
It's a forest fire that allows for new
growth and that's how those things are
put together and to see.
And it's useful to know too because if
you burn something off,
you might think,
well there's nothing left.
It's like,
that's not true.
If it's dead wood,
then you have room for new growth and
you want to be doing that on a fairly
regular basis.
That's the,
that's,
that's the snake that sheds its skin and
transforms itself.
Right?
That's,
that's the death and resurrection from a
psychological perspective,
it's exactly the same idea.
Now we don't know the upper limit to
that,
right?
Because we don't know what a person
would be like if they let everything
that they could let go,
let go and only let in what was
seemingly,
let's say,
but you can see that.
It's funny.
We don't know that to some degree you
can see people very far.
You can see people start to do that
without.
That's not an rare experience and people
improve very rapidly.
It can improve their lives very rapidly.
A lot of it's low hanging fruit,
like if you just stopped doing really
stupid things that you know are stupid,
your life improves a lot so and it,
it frees you up.
It also means there's a,
there's an element there that's also
associated with pride because people
tend to take pride in who they are and
that's a bad idea because that stops you
from becoming who you could be because
if you're proud of who you are,
you won't let that go when it's
necessary.
You won't step away from it,
you know,
and then you end up being your own
parody.
Something like that.
That's also a very bad idea.
You want to be continually stepping away
from your previous self,
and so,
and I guess part of that too is that you
have to decide,
you know,
are you,
are you order or chaos or you the
process that mediates between them and
if you're the process that mediates
between them,
you,
you are the thing transforms and that's
the right attitude for human being
because that's what we are.
We're the thing that voluntarily
confronts chaos and transformed.
That's what we are.
And so for better or worse,
you know,
that's our deepest biological essence
you might say.
And so you can let things go if you know
that there's more growth to come.
Yep.